you have 60 minutes our next guest can
make you look
10 years younger let's welcome back
brittany black from the jazzy wellness
hey brittany
hi how are you good doing good so some
people call it
turkey neck a double chin you have a
non-invasive way
of correcting this how it uses focused
ultrasound
to penetrate down to the muscle and it
stimulates your own collagen and elastin
production
so that'll help to regenerate your skin
so so how is the ultrasound skin lift
different from from other procedures
it's non-invasive non-surgical there's
no down time
we have people that come into it on
their lunch break you can pop into our
lunch and come out looking like this
some of the pictures we're seeing
here how many treatments until you start
seeing results like this
it's just a one-time treatment for
results like this that is amazing
how long do the treatments take each
treatment take
um depending on what area you do
typically 45 to 60 minutes
and then what does it feel like the
process
i would describe it as like a mild
tingling
maybe like a warm rubber band it's very
painless patients fall asleep all the
time
so you can come in there literally sit
there and watch a show on netflix and
have this procedure done
pretty much and then so once it's done
how long do the results last for
up to five years wow so the same day
you'll see
usually a textual improvement some
tightening um the tightening and lifting
portion usually comes in the next couple
months but it's every day you're looking
younger and younger and younger
we were talking we started things off
talking about the turkey neck and double
chin but we're seeing all these before
and after photos of
chin arms eye area what areas can you
treat
any area you can do anywhere on the body
you can do anywhere on the face
neck pretty much anywhere it also helps
to treat fat reduction as well
fat reduction so we're talking love
handles
love handles double chin if you have
loose little
area on your stomach from after having a
baby or something like that
we can treat that as well and so we're
talking about going in for 60 minutes
is it is it longer or shorter if you're
doing you're doing your stomach or
versus your double chin
typically still around 60 minutes that's
just it's an amazing procedure and just
blows my mind how fast you guys get it
done
we appreciate your time thank you so
much for joining us today brittany
thanks for having me all right give the
jazzy wellness a call at 702-800-7406
and they have a special offer for you
the first 10 callers receive 40 percent
off
non-surgical facelift amazing results
don't forget to give them a call
las vegas now we'll be right back